is it time to ban mp second jobs
for two weeks ministers have been
defending the principle of mp's second
jobs shouldn't mps be banned from having
second jobs all ministers have now found
themselves being probed over the second
jobs of owen patterson and jeffrey cox
nothing to say about torres leaves but
with labour about to pounce with their
own plans the government saying nothing
on second jobs was no longer an option
boris johnson's only public engagement
improving relations with his greek
counterpart while also writing a letter
to the speaker of the house of commons
angering some on his own side
the pm recommended the code of conduct
for mps should be updated stating they
should not accept paid work as advisers
or consultants and that any outside
activity undertaken by an mp should be
within reasonable limits the prime
minister is clear that the primary role
of a member of parliament must be to
serve their constituents and to serve
parliament clearly there is a difference
between a doctor a nurse maintaining
their professional qualifications or
someone who in their own time writes a
best-selling novel there's a distinction
between that and some of the concerns
that have clearly come to light in
recent days a bold move from boris
johnson today which just happened to
come seconds before kierstama announced
something very similar but here's the
rub neither the tory nor the labour
leaders actually want to ban second jobs
entirely so the fight will transfer to
what is acceptable and who polices the
line
but given the enormous scale of tory
backlash tonight that uncertainty is
bound to be exploited
it came after weeks of arguments in this
place culminating today as frustrated
tory ministers and backbenchers fell out
with one another
it was blue against blue former prime
minister against her successor owen
patterson broke the rules on paid
advocacy
and the attempt by right honourable and
honorable members of this house aided
and abetted by the government
under cover of reform of the process
effectively to clear his name
was misplaced ill-judged and just plain
wrong
kirstama had wanted to seize the
initiative today by announcing second
job restrictions when the pm beat him to
it by a matter of seconds he claimed
victory we've had two weeks of tourist
leads and corruption and
be under no illusion the prime
minister's only done this because his
back was against the wall because we the
labour party had put down a binding vote
for tomorrow so this is a significant
victory
for the labour party
tonight many tory mps are fuming as they
work out what this means for them more
changes means more debates so this isn't
going away sam coates sky news